good morning john it's wednesday july
18th
i'm gonna have to wait until friday to
do the green hair thing because today's
wednesday it's my wednesday and so i
must do a song
this is a pretty long song and i have to
fit it all in it's about harry potter
i'm getting kinda tired of this
republication media blitz you got
all of muggle kind under your spell
don't you know the whole world's already
gone and reserved a copy at amazon how
many more
books could you sell now give
me my book or go to hell
cause i need harry potter like a
grindelow needs water and as saturday
approaches my negros
oh axio deathly hallows incendio
book sales embargoes it'll be like
phoenix tears on a broken
nose yeah axio
deathly hallows
axio deathly hallows i'm getting kinda
petrified
what would ron do if hermione died or if
voldemort killed hedwig just for yucks
i have no confidence in theories about
the hat blood prince and what if
harry's brain is a horcrux
oh holy crap that would freaking suck
cause i need harry potter like a grindy
low needs water and as saturday
approaches my necros
axio deathly hallows incendio book sales
embargoes it'll be like
phoenix tears on a broken nose
whoa axio deathly hallows
what areas up the sleeves of jk rowling
i bet it has to do with sniffer
breakably vowing to protect that pure
blood plus face malfoy
but in the end i don't think it's gonna
matter if snape's good
or if he's bad because the weight of the
world rests on our boys
yeah the weight of the world bests on
our horn
cause we need harry potter like a grindy
low needs water and as that day
approaches our negroes
oh axio deathly house incendio
book sales embargoes it'll be like
phoenix tears on a broken nose
yeah deathly hallows
but mostly i'm just feeling sad
i know this could end real bad but i
wish it
didn't have to end at all
yeah i wish it didn't have to end at
all cause i couldn't care more about
harry potter if hogwarts was my alma
mater and as saturday approaches my
negros
the axio deathly house incendio
book sales embargoes it'll feel like
phoenix tears on a broken nose
yeah axio deathly hallows
oh axio
john i'll see you tomorrow